i went on twitter and i noticed i don't
always see that see my tweets but today
i looked and i saw a great tweet
actually that came from someone who had
some great questions and this all
started because i had put a tweet up
i had retweeted somebody's tweet about
dc pride and there was video of what was
going on in dc pride that looked
horrific um there were children there
there were little kids there there was
someone dancing nude provocatively
going up doing all sorts of weird things
you can go to my twitter account you can
see that and i wrote a society in decay
treats children this way which i 100
percent believe what's going on right
now with respect to kids is despicable
deplorable
horrific
there's going to be lasting consequences
on lasting damage if we don't do
something here well someone responded
jason jones i don't know jason at all he
is verified i have no idea who he works
where i have no idea what he does but
he asked some really really good
questions and i mean that sincerely i'm
not being sarcastic i know my brooklyn
sometimes
tone you never know if i'm being honest
or not but i actually really appreciate
this because
and i'll get to it in a second i've been
in this business for 10 years
i'm very lucky to have this microphone
right now to have this platform and i'm
doing my own thing for the first time
so there's going to be stuff that i said
that someone might look and say well
wait a minute but you said this
answer for yourself
that's totally fine i love it that's
what i'm here for i'm here to be
challenged
i'm here to think i'm here to explain
i'm here to have that conversation with
you
i'm here to be wrong sometimes
which i own up to as you know with covet
i've owned up to that quite a bit
i was wiping down packages guys outside
my door when kovitz started i was wiping
down my groceries it doesn't get more
humiliating than that and i've shared
that many at times with you so
i really appreciate this i'm not always
going to see it so i apologize if people
do it and i don't always answer but this
is really important people people need
to be able to ask these questions and we
need to have answers if i'm going to sit
here with this
i need to be willing to have this
conversation with you or it's not a real
conversation and then i'm a fraud
so this is what and i'm gonna pull it up
this is what the tweet said it said how
do you think we arrived at this critical
juncture jed pray tell and then below it
there's four tweets and this was this
was research heavy i mean that first
tweet on the left goes back the top left
goes back to 6 29 13 just to give you a
time frame for this one okay
so now i've been talking a lot about
this stuff with we did a show last week
where i talked about drag your kids to
pride event in dallas which involved
drag queens dancing with children and a
lot of the marketing and a lot of the
woke politics that's seeking to entangle
kids at this point and a lot of that
happens to be regarding the issue of
gender um
so i've been talking a lot about that
and talking about its dangers and how
this is wildly inappropriate for
children
so i want to go through these tweets and
just point out some of the differences
and how i feel about these things and
why i think these are really important
good questions to ask
so this first tweet i wrote in 6 29 13.
it's pride weekend in new york city that
means i'll see some of manhattan's most
gorgeous men parade and remember why i
loathe chris barron chris is gay openly
that's a joke he and i had for a long
time so yes well first of all
let me say this i've never actually been
to a pride parade where i stood there
and that was my purpose like i'm going
to the pride parade maybe there was one
in college i can't i may i have to i
have to really think about that
but i hate parades all of them i hate
the thanksgiving day parade i hate the
pride parade i hate the christmas parade
i hate all of them mostly because when
you live in a place like new york city
what that adds up to is horrible traffic
and an inability to exist so i'm not a
parade girl i'm not a parade girl when
it comes to anything
however when you walk around new york
city you see them you see the halloween
parade you have to duck and weave around
them and i will say
yes
there are a number of very good-looking
gay men out there that still exist that
was a horrible calamity i faced when i
was dating in my 20s
um that's a reality so yes this tweet i
stand by pride weekend in new york city
does mean that you will see some of
manhattan's most gorgeous bed parade
that is 100 true
um let's scroll to the next one
this gets juicy the next one is from 211
15 and i say i get what he's saying went
through the same evolution
obama axelrod mixing it up my views on
gay marriage this is the evolution of
obama on gay marriage as you know many
democrats came out they were against gay
marriage then they were for gay marriage
this was true this was honest this is
real
i felt very differently about this
initially i was opposed
and then i was supportive and i continue
to be supportive to be clear
i 100
support your right as a grown adult
as a grown person to make decisions for
yourself to have the freedom to live the
life that you want to live as long as
you're not hurting anyone else and as
long as you're not asking someone else
to pay for it so i stand by that i do i
do support i've been to gay weddings
i have friends that are married that are
straight that are in
very
wonderful marriages i have friends that
are married that are straight that are
in horrific
marriages that are um toxic and
problematic for the kids and they're
struggling in them i have gay friends
that are in toxic horrific marriages
where they're struggling and it's
problematic and i have gay friends that
are in marriages that are incredibly
healthy that are soon to welcome a child
so
my point here is that if you are an
adult
i stand by your freedom to live the life
you want so i stand by that tweet but i
i do own up to the evolution that i felt
differently at one time and then i
change which you will see happen over
the last 12 years i've been in media
you're going to see me change my mind on
stuff you're going to see me say i was
wrong you're going to see me say i feel
differently and here's why so that was a
moment where i was telling you
yes
this is this is i get it i get i get how
an evolution like that can happen that
was an honest moment for me
okay
this is a good one i mean that sincerely
um 4 25 16
i wrote to bakers denying gay couples
cakes citing religious freedom sin do
you quiz straight couples on whether
they have premarital sex before baking
um this was a legitimate question i was
struggling with the issue of
why why why don't they want to bake the
cake is this a good business practice
is this discriminatory
i ultimately found that i felt yes these
these companies should be allowed to
make these decisions a private business
so you should be allowed to make these
decisions in the same way that i'm going
to talk about a private business
actually that doesn't want to adopt pets
out to people unless they support gun
control i'm going to talk about why i
think that's bad policy i think this is
bad policy too by the way not baking a
cake for a gay couple that wants to get
married i think it's bad i just think
it's bad policy
um personally me personally
but do i think they should be allowed to
make that decision 100 but i was
legitimately asking if your problem is
and this was a curious question that i
had if you are legitimately having a
problem with people let's say you are
religious and i respect that 100 percent
i grew up i went to catholic school i
get it if that's your belief system and
you were actually saying
i don't want
to bake a cake for you because i believe
you're living in sin
and that's problematic for me i can
respect that line of thinking i really
can
but how do you apply that across the
board i was trying to say there's a lot
of people that are going to be living in
sin that are going to show up at your
door they're going to want a cake for a
birthday they're going to want a cake
for their wedding maybe they committed
maybe they they cheated on on someone
maybe that you know their behaviors
aren't going to be in line with god's
principles so i was legitimate i wasn't
even being sarcastic again i know i can
come off as sarcastic tyler's like you
don't say but i was legitimately asking
that question like
is this is this something that's on your
mind if you're
if you own a company you're baking is
this something you think about
universally or is this being targeted
toward gay people in which case it felt
discriminatory to me it felt specific it
felt personal
so i was asking
this was really me asking like hey
do we want to think about this
do we want to give this a pause do we
want to give this a second
and giving myself a second and i do this
i think out loud sometimes on twitter i
kind of throw things out there with
question marks
so that was an authentic moment um
and my my decision that i came to
ultimately and where i sit now is you
you should have a right to make these
decisions but i also will tell you when
i think it's it's bad policy
um
and that's going to happen so but a
great point to bring up and i appreciate
the screenshots honestly that's what
twitter is good for right you can go
back and just find everything that
someone ever said and it's there
um and i believe this is the last one
that was pulled
um
i guess someone had had a problem with
something i had said on the view and i
felt the need to clarify that i was a
big supporter of gay rights here you
should listen better which again
the conversation right then this is from
2016 the conversation that was happening
was about gay marriage
again i support the right of gay people
to marry
i want to go on record and say that i
support it
so that's what i was talking about i'm a
big supporter of gay rights i want gay
people to have i don't want them to be
discriminated against i don't want them
to be harassed
i don't want them to not be able to get
married and build a beautiful healthy
family that
you know if that's what they so choose
to do
um
that's not up to me i'm not here to tell
you how to live your life i i i don't
think anyone should be forced to endorse
it i don't think anybody should be
forced to
say they agree with it i don't think
anybody should be forced to fund it
but i do think that's how i feel i am a
supporter of people of humans and that
was the conversation that was having
right now i don't know what i said on
the view to make somebody mad who knows
i said things on the view to make people
mad all the time
but
i think it's important and then later on
also
um jason brought up another great point
that i want to address here because i
had responded to him and said i'm going
to address these i'm going to address
these on my show i think it's an impo i
think these are important questions i
think they're good questions i think
they're fair questions
and
i'm going to address them and i think
the response i had seen in there to
someone was
you know
i agree people can change but is she
just doing this because she's promoting
a new show so i that i just want to give
a second
i am not someone
who says
what i think people want to hear and i
will tell you the evidence is in my job
history
i would have had much more job security
i promise you if i had said
what people wanted me to say
what the establishment wanted me to do
and say you will notice that there have
been times i've been let go
there have been times that i've clashed
on air that have been uncomfortable
that's because i don't lie on camera
when i tell you what i actually feel
i tell you what i actually feel i'm
being honest with you so
there is no way on god's green earth and
i say this to the person who asked jason
i don't know you but i appreciate you
for bringing these to the table
there is no way i would be sitting here
and doing this
right now
if i didn't want to tell you exactly how
i feel in this moment there's no point
there's no point i would have just sat
where i was
i'd been in numerous positions where i
could have just said what do you need me
to say and i would have said it and i
would have had a great paycheck and
great job secure i'm not doing that
anymore like i've never been that person
to tell you know to say what you need me
to say but i'm not in those spaces i'm
here because i want to tell you how i
feel i want to speak the truth if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]